welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and the new mutants was the first
big footage released from comic con at
home
2020 the cursed film of the past few
years they kept getting delayed we got
the movie's first two minutes in a
trailer with creepy creepy nightmare
faces
and if you look closely enough some
really cool easter eggs and visual
details that could explain this movie's
dark plot
and maybe just maybe connections to
other marvel films
currently we're looking at a new mutant
release date of august 28 2020.
we'll see about that i'm gonna break
down everything that you might have
missed from this footage spoiler warning
in case i predicted anything to write
and ruin your life
huh breakdown of new stuff what this
feels like
here we go the movie's opening scene
begins with a voiceover from danny
moonstar the mutant
mirage a native american girl who can
manifest illusions into reality she's
haunted by this movie's antagonist the
demon bear
her narration discusses the background
of this native american mythology about
how
everyone has two bears inside them
fighting for their souls a
good bear and an evil bear her mutant
ability caused
this inner dark entity to become a real
world threat and i assume it comes from
her just from the comics yeah but also
she has this cool
bear necklace that she wears on her and
notice the quality she associates with
the evil bear
the other is all things evil
fear shame and self-destruction
yeah shame growing up catholic shame was
told to me to be a good thing i'm sorry
i'm sorry i'm sorry but it's cool it's a
little detail showing how
for these kids shame over their
abilities is so
self-destructive and toxic it amounts to
a force of evil that this demon bear can
use to [ __ ] with them the demon bear
attacks their community here
probably leading to mirage and
authorities to think she herself
is criminally responsible he probably
would have been safer now it's only the
opening scene but already i'm loving the
camera work here
a long unbroken tracking shot following
danny and her dad out the fiery home out
in the snow
and then we get this overhead push in as
the chaos explodes in the audio
soundscape around her but staying on her
face
as she suddenly wakes up in the
middlebury hospital which i've talked
about in other videos could be a nod to
nathan milbury nathaniel essex mr
sinister who was set up
long ago to be a future x-men villain in
the x-men apocalypse post-credit scene
maybe he'll be connected maybe it won't
but as she looks up
wolf spain is looking down at her from
the vent that's a pretty terrifying
thing to wake up to
i'm sorry i'm sorry i'm sorry all the
people who live in my vents let's move
on to the new trailer because it does
just enough to get me excited for this
movie again maybe it's just because you
know i'm dying of thirst and any
new superhero movie will be something i
devour get new looks at eliana rasputin
aka magic
the sister two colossus remember him
from the deadpool movies
assembling over her arm is the eldritch
armor she carries with her a
psychic blade called the soul sword
charlie heaton from stranger things
plays sam guthrie cannonball
he can blast himself forward with
invulnerability you can see he attaches
himself to this big
concrete block maybe to tow it along
with him when he cannonballs as a
separate projectile that might be able
to break through that force field that
contains them in this hospital
i think that field is being projected by
dr cecilia reyes
maisie williams from game of thrones
plays rain sinclair wolfsbane
who can shapeshift into a wolf notice
how that w brand that we've seen on her
neck is also scarred into her back
i'm wondering if her wolf form was
branded with a w a few times on the neck
and on the shoulder by fearful locals
trying to tag this
menace werewolf so that they would be
able to id her when she shape-shifted
back
and then there's roberto de costa
sunspot bobby manipulates solar energy
to raise his body heat to extreme
temperatures
similar to the human torch but it's not
the same thing he doesn't say flame on
it's totally different now this movie
appears to be designed as a surrealist
institutional horror
with kids trapped in a paranormal
nightmare hospital inspired by nightmare
on elm street dream warriors with a lot
of that same
bendy wall imagery that wes craven love
to use we get a look at some of those
nightmare entities haunting them
underneath those happy face masks are
well less happy faces sharpty no eyes
similar to the crooked man look see now
overhead shots of those guys show that
their bodies are covered in
tattoos i'm wondering if they could be
reflections of iliana's inner demons
maybe from
gropey dudes with russian prison tattoos
whose eyes maybe she never got to see
that's why they don't have eyes now
perhaps here they have been accidentally
manifested into reality by mirage it's
just worth noting that iliana seems
particularly triggered by them
and she is the one who is most directly
confronting them maybe mirage will be
triggering
all of their inner demons they'll have
to individually confront while this
looks mostly like mirage's story magic
definitely seems the most active using
her powers of teleportation
and the soul sword to slice through
these enemies and of course to attempt
to slay the demon bear but she won't be
doing it alone because look closely
beside
ileana as she prepares to battle this
demon bear there is
a flapping creature beside her just
begin later in the trailer
and flaps above the demon bear as she
fights it i did see this briefly in the
background of the trailer i broke down
earlier this year we now know
this is lockheed an x-men character it's
an alien dragon companion actually to
shadow cat kitty pride in the comics but
in this movie it's going to be a
companion to magic and during all this
battle imagery part of the way magic
appears to fight the demon bears to drop
it into this red skied world i'm
assuming this is limbo another dimension
that magic is able to access via her
teleportation because if you look
closely at the background of the portal
she travels through to attack the
baldies it is that same
red hellish background of limbo that
she's coming from whether we get to see
this in miraculously reopen cinemas in
late august or if they just cave and
release it on disney plus i am certainly
more excited to see it than i was
it may just be a leftover piece of
shelved what might have been superhero
horror cinema
an unfortunate victim of corporate
reshuffling during fox's sale to disney
a few years back but there is still
a chance elements from this universe
could find their way to the mcu
because we'll hopefully be getting more
information on one division soon but we
do know that former x-men movie quick
silver actor evan peters has been cast
in that show in a mystery role which has
led some to believe that the
mcu might use wanda maximoff's
exploration of the multiverse to retcon
past x-men film elements like evan
peters quicksilver and maybe like the
new mutants
into the mcu multiverse maybe one of the
mini tv channel realities wanda blinks
through could be
this movie's limbo like it could just be
that simple and that non-controversial
and fun
comment down below with your thoughts on
this new mutants film and join our
discussion on discord by becoming a
patron at patreon.com
new rockstars follow me on instagram
eavos follow new rockstars and subscribe
for breakdowns of everything you love
thanks for watching
[Music]
you